fa 1 tuexcites tout le
[Applaudissements]
monde c'est pour
toi tu me
regardes ah ouais émotion ou Michel
Marie je parle de toi parce qu'avec ta
petite voix il est 3h30 tes petite
manie tu as les bercer sur ma vie des
milliers de
roses Michel Marie tu dis que la vie
c'est une bague à chaque droit au soleil
de
Floride moi mes poches sont vides et mes
yeux pleurent de
Mo mais je
viens ne parle que de toi oui Michel
mais la musicien qui fait jouer ses
mains sur un morceau de
bois plus bleu que le ciel
[Applaudissements]
autour dans la pombre de ta rue Michel
Marie
m'entends-tu tu fait tout ça que pour
cette
phrase
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ché rose rose est avec nous aujourd'hui
ça va rose ça va très bienfant ma chérie
tu viens d'où moi je viens de Paris
[Musique]
Paris sous le ciel de Paris marche des
amoureux c'est bon ça suffit
entraîné par la foule qui nous traîne
nous entraîne nous
éloigne
reste ça
suffit dans le Tex Franch je
suis c'est Pierre fou à tous qu'est-ce
que tu dis c'est Piaf ouvert à
tous préféré on aurait préféré que la
vanne passe du premier coup mais bon
elle est passée quand même on va pas se
mentir non mais attends mais je suis un
fou de Piaf moi incroyable je suis un
fou de Piaf moi ou bien sûr qu'est-ce
que tu veux tu veux que je te chante
quoi de de Piaf toujours ou l'me à la
moto ah
tu connais l'HME à la moto bien
sûr mais avec ou il faut la faut une
Corée faut un truc faut il portait des
culottes des bottes de moto un blouson
de cuir noir avec un aigle sur le dos
montre qu'il passait comme un boulet de
canon se la terreur dans toute la
région
jamais
ouais les ongles pleins de Cambou mais
sur le B' il avait un tatouage avec un
cœur bleu sur la peème et juste à
l'intérieur on lisait maman je
t'aime
merci
c'est bon c'est
bon c'est
bon tu veux
liberté fa
de prendre
une
ma liberté longtemps je t'ai gardé comme
une perle
rare ma liberté c'est toi qui m'a aidé à
larguer les
Amares pour aller n'importe où pour
aller jusqu'au bout des chemins de
fortune pour queillir en rêvant une rose
des vents sur un rayon de
[Musique]
lune
merci
mer est-ce que tu veux tu une autre de
Serge voir si tu la reconnais benim
c'est pour toi vasy il faut prendre une
te
terassera la femme qui est dans mon lit
n'a plus 20 ans depuis
longtemps les yeux
cernés par les années par les amours au
jour le jour le corps usé trop caressé
trop souvent mais trop mal
aimé
merci c'est tout pour moi oh là
là une palette une palette une palette
j'ai une palette dans le camion
c'est pour toi c'est pour toi benï is
non mais jeve je suis bu c'est pour toi
ben je déteste flatter je déteste
flatter mais ce que vous venez de faire
c'est digne des plus grandos numéro de
Las
Vegas ouais on pe on peut pas finir par
un petit as naavour comme ça juste
balader VO ouais on fait quoi alors ave
on fait laquelle la naav on fait ouais
je pense emmenz-moi emenez-moi alors
mettezla mettezla pas facile la mettre
est ouais mais avec la ch
[Musique]
mus ver où le poid et l'enu
cour ils arriv ventreour fr les
B il
VI vagab ble
[Musique]
de
inconnu et d'éternelles été où l'on vit
presque nu sur les plages moi qui n'ai
connu toute ma vie que le ciel du
Nord j'aimerais débarbouiller ce gris
environ de bord attention
menz-moi au bout de la terre emenez-moi
au pays des merveilles il me semble que
la misère
serait moi pénible au
soleil dans les bars à la
jour merci cétait pour ben c'est une
spéciale benï ce
soir ça me va droite au cœur est-ce que
tuen veux une petite dernière pour toi
moi je on reste surenavour ou on change
qu-ce que tu veux bien moi j'aime bien
navour tu veux quoi tu veux Laem ou ah
ou tu veux pas br
formidable c'est pour moi c'est pour
[Applaudissements]
moi
formidable
véritable je vis pouvoir jour enfin te
le
dire te
l'écrire dans quoi dans langue de
Shakespeare non on l'a pas kiffé ça on
l'IME bien on l'a pas kiffé C on l'a pas
kiffé on l'a pas kiffé on peut pas
terminer sur ça benï tu choisis une
dernière chanson et après on va
accueillir Sacha base rest sur non Jin
c'est
beau lesux en ce moment c'est ch changer
yeux chux ouais mais j'arrive plus à
loucher
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là moi je dire il y a un chanteur que je
kiffe que tout le monde kiffe
niska qui
aussi my c'est
[Applaudissements]
toujours
mes
amis je vous dit est bonne ça ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas
écé je serais plus
[Musique]
triste je Neev
voir je avec raison
essayer de répondre à ma
question qui saura qui saura qui
saura qui saura me faire oublier
dites-moi on est déçu on est déçu on est
déçu en fait ça fait
longtemp c'est quoi la meilleure chanson
en fait meilleure comme ça à chanter
crazy frog ouis crazy frog
ah c'est toi qui va choisir parce que tu
es celui que j'ai le plus fracassé cette
semaine c'est vrai et je sais que je
vais recommencer tout à l'heure ave
plaisir donc autant finir maintenant on
finir maintenant avec toi Johnny pour
finir ça vous é encore Johnny non non
Johnny
laquelle non l'envie on l'a déjà fait
ouais allumer le feu ouais allumer le
feu normalement alors normalement
normalement je ne la fais jamais le
vendredi ch sans rigoler jamais veille
de shabbat allumer le feu pas à shabbat
je suis désolé pardon les gars je
n'allume pas le feu je n'allume pas le
feu Gill réfléchis alors jeis faire une
chanson pour Daniel quelqu'un qui est
quelqu'un de
vivant ça va je t' réveilléou non je
choisis vas-yy alors il y a une chanson
que j'ai tout le temps à la bouche c'est
le zizi
pierre c'est
insable insupportable mais je la connais
leou
mais on faitin de fois c'est qui décide
Johny je voudis Johny plaisir ça fer
plaisir je sais pas le pénitentier
pén
je que je
t'ae merci is ça bouge pas ça faites
chier hein je suis pas là pour
ça ah
ouais il me faut de
[Musique]
l'eau
tes cheveux
s'étalent comme un soleil
d'été et que ton
oreiller ressemble au champ de
bléand l'OM la
lumière dessine sur ton
corps des montagnes des forêts
et
[Musique]
trés je t'aime que je t'aime que je
t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime que
je
[Musique]
t'aime quand ta bouche se fait
douce quand ton corps se fait
Durand le ciel dans tes yeux d'un seul
coup N plus
pur quand tes mains voudrai
bien quand tes toi n'os pas quand tu as
plus deur dis
non du tout
petit je t'aime que je t'aime Gill
verd que
je que je t'aime
gilverdz Gill
verdeise qu'on
ver j'ai j'ai Verdette j'ai verd j'ai
Verdette j'ai Verdette j'ai
Verdette c'est pour
toi non
franchement tuas eu un truc j'ai failli
pleurer vous m'avezu vraiment j'ai dans
la VO je sais quand ton corps se fait
dur j'ai
senti alors